[Music]
here we are again
here we are again i love it good to see
you you're
in the the the dark cavernous
is that a man cave is that a bar where
are you
yeah it's just i'm just a very
light-colored
alternate universe yeah you look uh
a lot more peaceful than my kind of
dungeon i'm i'm down here in the uh
this is the bar actually but now it's
office
it was a bar it was kind of a cool place
to hang out and have people
friends over but in covid times it's uh
an office and i got a mic hooked up here
and all my computer crap and
mail and all the other stuff so i feel
like all of your bdsm
dungeon equipment is hiding that is you
do you want to talk about that no no
look look i am
actually in my acupuncture office you
may recognize the acupuncture shelves
behind me
i am in fact in an acupuncture office
but it's not mine
are you just renting one out or what are
you doing i'm borrowing
fast wi-fi in an undisclosed rural
location
where my internet speed is otherwise 0.5
megabits per second
which doesn't allow us to do calls like
this yeah so where are you i am
on a farm and in the middle of the woods
i have a bear
living about well in fact
probably hundreds of feet from me at
times a real
full-on bear yes a huge bear it's a
gigantic healthy
black bear like we have a friendly
trained one kind of thing or
not trained no tricycles no tricks no
dancing and
on the sidewalk for pennies this is a
wild black bear we haven't yet
met i've met fox
coyote all sorts of other animals but
have not yet met the bear just seen
photographs
that my friends have taken have you done
bear training
i have not done any bear training so
that's a real thing yeah no i haven't
but uh
our mutual friend mike mazer sent me
photos last weekend he went up and
did some he lives in montana and he did
some bear training like they bring in
real loud bears of the tackle you
that's where he's like wrestling with
big dudes with beards is that
pretty much like san francisco san
francisco style yeah
exactly i think i did otter training
when i was in san francisco but no real
legitimate bear training
i've done raccoon and squirrel those are
my two certifications
if if people have not actually seen
kevin's raccoon video
he's not lying he he didn't actually
do any raccoon training but you got
thrown into the swimming pool like
turned into an
olympic swimmer in mumbai real quick to
defend your
your your little pup toaster people can
search kevin
rose raccoon and get to that i haven't
done bear training if you're in montana
you need legit bear training because you
have
terrestrial great white sharks aka
grizzly bears which are
very very different from the supposedly
the black girls are pretty chill right
they seem like they avoid humans
and tend not to prey upon humans so
that's a good thing
you carry bear's braid though i take it
i do not
currently carry bear spray i make a lot
of noise when i'm hiking
but that's about it at this point
probably should do more
research but one of the things i've been
getting into is plant and
i suppose this would be a subset of that
but tree identification so that's been
something i'm
spending a lot of time on i've been
doing probably two to three hours of
hiking
in the woods per day and that
involves a whole bunch of gear aside
from my
my lack of bear spray so i wear a
limited pants they have permethrin
in the fabric so you avoid ticks which
is super important if you're anywhere
certainly on the east coast and anywhere
else and then
have you ever seen a goruck rucksack i
believe they're based in
in san francisco no i don't believe so
there are backpacks designed
by uh well the ceo and founder who's
former special forces
to carry uh customized weight plates
so for ace a replacement to running
because i like to think that
i like to want to run but i don't
actually enjoy running very much and it
bothers my knees you can do these
weighted hikes where you'll have say 20
or 30
or more pounds on your back but the
backpacks are just
specifically designed to carry these
square weight plates that sit
high on your upper back so that you can
have better ergonomics as you hike and
it's been awesome i'll just
i was like i'm curious about that
because i have a weighted vest
that i have you know the standard one
like you order on amazon and i always
use it on the treadmill sometimes just
for like a super low grade
uh but you know adds an extra 15 or 20
pounds on how is this i think it's just
position the weights position better so
you don't hurt your back
the way that it's pitched and i've i've
only used a weight vest
once just as a quick side note so when i
use the weight vest
i had no point of reference this was
probably 2008 or 2009 when i was working
on the four hour body
and i thought i can work with the weight
vest and this was but i think it was
before they used weight vests and the
crossfit games and so on
and i had no idea how much weight to use
and i was like i'll just get like 50 or
60 pounds that seems like
it's a good starting point so i put on
60 pounds
and i would usually go for like a three
mile walk
in san francisco and i got three miles
out and i was like i'm [ __ ] done
i can't do this and so i left the best
on the sidewalk
and walked back i couldn't i couldn't
hack it it was
also in the summer but if you read the
website
would be led to believe that the vests
have more of a suffocating effect
because you also are carrying weight on
chest these are intended to mimic
more of long distance piggy biking
ergonomics yeah right and it's actually
piggybacking but with the weight higher
up on your back so i've found it
surprisingly comfortable i have
some spinal issues in my upper thoracic
back
so let's just call it lower cervical
and wearing backpacks for long
periods really bothers my back but these
bags
actually allow me to train usually for
no more than about an hour and a half
without any subsequent back pain as long
as i don't overdo it so it's been it's
been really nice to build up the lower
legs
i'm also jumping rope using both in a
way to
prepare for possible trail running
and feeling great feeling just fantastic
i'll listen to audio books or do phone
calls typically
while i'm doing that two questions one i
had always heard at least back in the
day like
when you're backpacking they always say
get a backpack where all the weight is
kind of pushed down to your hips you're
carrying it on your hips and it's not so
much on your back
why wouldn't you want something like
that and to your jump rope point
did you hear that tyson's going to fight
again i did hear that tyson's going to
fight against crazy
it is crazy well so the hip stuff all
right so the hip stuff
i i would imagine if you are carrying a
lot more weight
or if you're just hiking for efficiency
and not as a workout that probably makes
a lot of sense
what i have found personally is that if
i have a backpack with a weight strap
and shoulder straps maybe i'm just using
them
incorrectly but it tends to pull me
backwards and i jump my head forward
quite a lot
there are training recommendations and
guidelines on this this site i think
it's just goruck.com
and i followed those so they encourage
you not to lean forward they encourage
you to stand up straight
and very deliberately do not have a
chest strap or
a waist harness i'm sure you could train
with
other approaches but the fact of the
matter is my let's just call
upper middle back always hurt after a
short period of time of caring backpacks
wherever i would be walking around in
the city whether it was san francisco
years ago
or in austin or elsewhere and doing this
i got a great workout but without that
subsequent it's really spinal pain
basically the musculature around the
spine or maybe maybe even the connective
tissue
i've had some of that so once when it
seizes up too i don't know how many
times you've had your back seize on you
where you're like you just can't move oh
my god it's like it's like worst
it is yeah and it's like i have two
little monkeys like hanging on me all
day long with little girls you know and
i'm just like
they just tweak you one way or now like
i'm in my 40s if i cough
my with my head pointed the wrong
direction my back is just like
just like seizes up on you well i feel
like that's a good segue
to uh what lazy
bastards we are compared to tyson who's
in his 50s isn't he i know he's like
six almost 60. so let me ask you a
question like straight up
10 million dollars no no that's not
enough money for tim ferriss
tim ferriss uh 200 million dollars
no bullshitting no falling to the ground
would you step in the ring with tyson
today
absolutely not no i wouldn't there's no
[ __ ] way
you don't think you could win well
number one
absolutely would not win dude you have a
black belt
i mean yeah in judo i mean it's sport
judo it's very different
from like raised in i think it's about
brownsville
with you know how many rounds could you
go just
oh absolutely if we're talking boxing or
anything
unless i jumped guard and just hung on
for dear life like a
koala bear i would not last one round i
probably
wouldn't think it last minute i think
you could last one round i don't think
so man
if you covered up completely like you
just put your arms
in full turtle position yeah
and just let him punch you in your arms
your [ __ ] head would fly off
yeah i most people have not been hit
by a trained fighter i've been hit by
trained fighters
and it's a lot worse than you think it
is
it's a lot worse and as someone who's
had head trauma before
and concussions because i was never a
very good striker i was i was a better
grappler
and it wasn't a great grappler either
but i was i was decent
with a lot of wrestling background in
judo and so on but i would just get
whacked in the head have you ever seen
spaceballs yes of course
where uh what dark helmet is
at bay with one arm and he's swinging he
isn't hitting anything i was basically
dark helmet whenever i sparred because
i was heavy for my height and so i'd end
up with these goddamn
six foot two like 150 pounders who would
just
tee off on my head from a distance
non-stop
and i ended up i think with some
long-term
damage and consequences from that so
traumatic brain injury i have zero
interest in these days
so i would not for any price not even if
it was like grappling like mma style
with tyson
the problem is i wouldn't risk it i
wouldn't risk it man yeah you could
definitely get in one good shot
that's right that's right all that's all
it takes right like he yeah you could
try
and then he just needs to get the right
angle and then you're out
it's just over the other thing to
remember too is that
speed goes with age i mean speed is one
of the first things if you watch
say roy jones jr or a lot of these
fighters
who had a winning style predicated on
speed once they lose half a step they
start getting knocked out
tyson was very very fast but he's also
ungodly strong and he's got
old man strength that yeah has not
diminished
have you watched some of his videos i
have watched
some of his backing shape videos yeah
his pad and knit work videos oh
god and uh we'll put some in the show
notes
for people to to check out if they just
search you know mike tyson
new videos i'm sure they'll pop right up
uh
they're terrifying they're really really
terrifying because i've i've been hit by
some
decent strikers and
i mean you feel afterwards you're
the bruising of your brain i mean your
brain is bound ricocheted off the sides
of your skull
like a big ice cube being shaken in a
[ __ ] shaker
and that's not good for you you know it
can contribute to depression it can
contribute to dementia
early onset alzheimer's like i am so
uninterested yeah i'll take my chances
with the bear over tyson anytime
i don't know four four hour body tim
would have would have might have been
interested a few a few years ago
four hour body tim was like evil knievel
right like i'm going to jump
grand canyon and just wipe out into the
wall break every bone of my body and
at the time i think i just assumed that
i could automatically repair
all of that and the fact is not to imply
that there's a lot of that in the book i
don't think there is
uh but there's a certain
sense of immortality or
invincibility that you have when you're
younger which you
you learn is very misplaced when you get
a little bit older and that's not to
play the crotchety all like oh my god
once it's 30 it's all downhill once it's
35 it's all downhill you always meet
lazy people who say that [ __ ] because
they just don't want to they just don't
want to put in the work
because it takes a little more work when
you're not in hormonal nirvana
to you know keep that little python
that's swallowed a goat physique
you know like dad bought at bay uh but
the fact the matter is like without
higher testosterone levels and so on
your recovery time and
and everything else is is extended right
so i am so uninterested in injuries
these days especially during covid right
the last thing i want to do is
put up some home-based parkour
course and like break a risk trying to
scale the garage and then have to go to
the emergency room
no way no thank you yeah
but who now he's fighting oh roy jones
jr onyx yeah
with mike tyson you don't know what mike
might do is it roy jones jr that would
be a huge weight class mismatch let me
just
fact check this real fast but roy jones
jr was boxing not that long ago right
it's been it is it is roy jones jr oh it
is roy jones jr yeah eight round
exhibition fight
interesting all right so roy jones jr i
watched
a lot and these are both fighters
who capitalized on
incredible speed right and now they're
older they're both strong
tyson absolutely has a strength
advantage oh jesus tyson is
510 240. roy jones
jr is 193. i don't know what his height
is
it doesn't say here 193 to 240 that's a
big weight difference
yeah you really don't want to get hit by
either of these guys
uh so to make
that exhibition looks like an exhibition
fight on september 12th that's
really soon that
roy jones jr is gonna have to dance he's
really gonna have to dance and i don't
know
the last time that he had a dance card
with stakes quite this high
i mean and he might be laughing all the
way to the bank but honestly it's like
if mike tyson hits you hard enough
you're gonna have trouble finding the
bank
yeah exactly
oh my god i'll definitely watch that
fight though are you kidding
that's crazy it's good to see him back
though man
you know the cool thing about it is i
saw tyson being interviewed
and he pledged 100 of the proceeds to
charity
um he doesn't care about making any
money off this is
that's not where his happiness comes
from anymore like it just seemed like
really
like a different version of tyson that
was refreshing to see
you know it seems like he's done a lot
of a lot of work on himself
yeah it seems that way i mean it's uh i
you know i'm not fighting off ears
anymore i don't think
biting off ears that's a good start in
self-development
stop biting off ears and it seems like
he's done a lot of work i saw a video
on which was an interview of tyson
describing
his five meow five methoxy
dmt experience oh crazy yeah
yeah and i i don't know who the the
sitters were
for that but
you either have to be really really
really good
with lots of safeguards or you have to
be incredibly [ __ ] stupid
to be in a room where you volunteered to
hold down mike tyson when he's on
five nba dmt [ __ ] that
i know that thanks yeah you get a big
padded room
and you kind of have to do it via like
yeah like
through the phone yeah exactly
all right mikey here's the two here's
the tube through the window
yeah exactly you're gonna do great
oh my god it's like the hulk when he
like erupts and just like you know you
can't contain him
yeah you don't want to be you don't want
to be anywhere close to that so what
have you been up to man it's been
actually quite a while since we've
caught up it's been
at least a few weeks since we had a
proper
proper conversation yeah i know and then
our last podcast that we did
i mean we were just in like a horrible
place like our last podcast was when
covid was really starting to hit
and we're both like well we'll see i
hope to see you sometime
you know like it was like we thought the
end was near
lisa you still kind of feel that way
though huh
well not the end but
lots of changes for sure i'm less
concerned about the virus
wiping out everyone which i didn't think
was going to happen to begin with but i
didn't like the
at the time what we understood to be the
characteristics and kinetics
of the virus still very very glad that i
made the public statements and published
the blog posts that i did which i still
stand by but
i am very concerned about
the the secondary and third order
effects
of economic destruction and
high rates of unemployment uh very
understandable uh anger and
frustration and
strong emotions coming from not
having work uh not having a sense of
purpose
for millions of people and also
just having a very very polarized
political machines who are capitalizing
on that heightened emotion
to try to further their aims on on all
sides
this is this is this is a defining
i would say characteristic of a sort of
opportunistic
political maneuvering so i'm i'm very
concerned
uh about the country so i'm not the the
game is far from over if we had a
working vaccine tomorrow
and were prepared to distribute what
percentage of the us
do you think would volunteer even if
they were told that
that it were mandatory who would comply
what percentage of the population do you
think would comply and actually get a
vaccine
and since we don't have any
state-to-state
restrictions in terms of travel i mean
there are recommended
14-day uh right self-quarantines and so
on but there's no real enforcement
there's no real follow-up that's right
yeah so what i mean what percentage of
the country do you think would actually
take a vaccine
fully distributed thought to be
effective
yeah i mean i think i guess it also
depends on the window of time that
you're you're talking about right i mean
i think that a lot more people will take
it a month three versus month one
you know yeah so um
i would say that does it well i guess my
the
question though is does it really matter
like you and i are going to take it
right
like just there'll be a certain subset
of people that won't
and you know it's like you're kind of
rolling the dice with your own life and
at that point there's you've done all
you can do
yeah i mean it sounds horrible to say
that but like how do you
you can't force someone to like stick a
needle in their arm so
you have to do the best you can at
education at demonstrating
uh safety and efficacy and then you know
hope for the best
i would say though it's probably gonna
be more than you would think
uh well what percentage of folks get the
flu shot every year i guess that would
be a good proxy
um yeah i don't know
and then and then i would say it will be
higher than that because flu is very
optional for a lot of people not as
deadly so
um yeah it's it's hard it's hard to to
back into a number like that but i would
imagine it would be somewhere
around 70 or greater would you think
you were probably thinking like 20 i'm
thinking 20 to 30 percent by month three
that would be my that would be my guess
that's what i would bet are you doing it
month one
you know this is this is where we're
going to get ourselves into trouble i'm
not a medical professional
not giving medical advice i would not
want to be the first monkey shot into
space
but we might edit this out later because
i also don't want to discourage people
from getting a vaccine but if we're
breaking
every land speed record in
developing a vaccine for a virus that we
understand
very incompletely you know i have my own
misgivings i i
do think vaccines are incredibly
valuable
to the individual and to community and
humanity overall
and we we simply don't have a lot of
data on
on this virus so well to your point
about the economy though that i think
that's going to be
the difficult piece of this in getting
folks back to work and getting the
average consumer to trust
restaurants again to trust bars again to
trust all
concert venues all the things that we
used to do to
to drive up the economy and and you know
uh
i just can't see it bouncing back as
fast as people
have said it's going to um i think i i
think we're at minimum
you know a year and a half two year
yeah tough that feels right tough trench
yeah so
i guess you put it as you poetically put
it to me some time ago i think we're in
for a slow donkey
i think i think we are looking
at a slow donkey here yeah sometimes
people quote you and you're like there's
no way i said that like i definitely
said that that
sounds like something i would say um so
well here's the crazy thing man like
i've been thinking more about universal
basic income and and
the one thing the biggest at first i was
like no there's no way why do we need it
seems like a waste of money you know
it's like just
giving out money doesn't seem to be a
solution for anything and then
two weeks ago a new
uh api came out from a group called
openai
which is this artificial intelligence
group have you seen anything created by
this gpt3 have you seen this at all
i've seen chris sacca's experiments with
it i haven't played with it yet
he's he seems incredibly impressed i
don't know
what his involvement is if any but it's
it's coming
so what i saw seems nuts some of the
demos that i've seen lately
are you give the ai a couple websites so
you go like here's a website i like and
here's another website i like now
design me a website that looks like
those websites but is about a text
based messaging app and it literally
created
a beautiful ready to go fully designed
website
in like minutes that it came up with
it and you're like well there goes all
the graphic design jobs
like you know like maybe not in the next
six months or next year but that is
where it's going
and like if that's gonna be on a whole
like a.i
is gonna kill so many technical jobs and
and it's it's just crazy i i don't see
any way out of this
like you have to become like a basket
weaver or a potter
or a co or a cult leader those are
that's immediate
that's the first thing daria said i was
talking my wife about it she was like
you know it's going to be
down to like artisan craft like the ai
can't do like touched by human hands i'm
like well
yeah but like how many people need
baskets like
how many you know what i mean like how
many artisan like
artists do we need to be doing this like
i i just don't know that there's that
many jobs there so
maybe something like universal basic
income does make sense when
eventually that hits um and i worry they
they talk
the talk now on the street is that a lot
of these jobs just aren't going to come
back
you know they talk about the talk on the
street that's a phrase
like the street like wall street oh okay
yeah that's got it the word on the
street
around the neighbors
[Laughter]
i got it all right yeah the jobs aren't
going to come back yeah i mean
if if this is like v0 right if this is
rough draft it's hugely
i mean it's awesome in the like 18th
century sense of the word
right i mean it's awe-inspiring and kind
of staggering in its implications and
also really terrifying
it is it's like writing books now
like you're you're going to be soon out
of work did you see some of the stuff
that's writing like you can say
uh write me a bedtime story and then it
just goes and creates these
beautiful like you could take that tweak
a couple words and like put your name on
it and people will do that
and it's not going to show up again in
any plagiarism dictionaries or anything
like that it'll
but it'll be like 90 ai written
so i mean that would be a way to rough
draft
stuff right as as i although i have to
imagine it's pulling from
other sources that might end up
then having claims of plagiarism but
from other sources in the terms of
creating its its mental model and
understanding model
of the data so but so are we all right
like the only reason you can write your
books is because you're pulling from all
your childhood experiences and all the
other crap so it's the same
all the crappy childhood experiences
also
saka for those people who don't know
very
very very successful investor
previous operator first fund of
delivered something like 250x
i guess and has done very well
he drafted a number of tweets and then
let uh open ai but that's not the phrase
he used it's what was the other term
that you used
oh gpt-3 gpt-3 what does that refer to
uh that's just their most uh recent
iteration of this type of technology it
was two and now it's three
i don't know what the gpt stands for
exactly i can find out though okay
catchy catchy first i thought he was
talking about grand theft auto and he'd
spoke too much weed i wasn't sure what
he was texting me about
and he wrote a string of tweets and then
he let
gpt three write the next two or three
and effectively impossible
to tell apart right i mean they did seem
like tweets that he would write
it was spooky it's really cool it it for
for those of you that are listening
they're like i have no idea what these
guys are talking about like definitely
go on twitter um type that in and just
look for they have so many examples
being tweeted out they're just fun
they're crazy and fun and wacky and but
but
it's it's one of those things where you
realize
a major shift has happened like this is
truly a big
uh ai shift and that you know i talked
to siri today and it doesn't understand
half the [ __ ] i'm trying to tell it
and and you go into what you watch what
this thing can do and you're like wow
like this is an order of magnitude
better than what we had just a couple
months ago you know
hey siri tell me predict what the slow
donk is going to do
slow donkey
[Music]
oh my god that's so [ __ ] creepy man
why does siri uh it's because i said hey
siri auto activated on my phone and then
had
slow donkey i didn't get that could you
try again all right siri
that's enough out of you oh boy
so you were asking what what we've been
up to i mean i i just for me it's been
more the same in portland though you
know just kind of like enjoying
the protests out here like not enjoying
them that was a joke it's it's been
really
brutal downtown in portland um
the weather's been fantastic uh but you
know it's like you gotta look on the
bright side with all this stuff going on
and
and try and find ways to i don't know
just
return to some resemblance of like
some kind of normal and i don't know how
you do that for for us it's like dary
and i like on friday nights even though
we don't leave the house like we
actually get dressed up like we're gonna
go out to dinner
and i know that sounds cheesy but it's
like breaking that
pajama routine is a big deal you know
and like
eating outside now is nice like we have
a backyard in portland so we can go eat
outside which
is is a huge change um but yeah how
about how about you guys how is it um
what have you been up to well it's it's
made a big difference
at least from my mental well-being uh
to move from a more urban environment to
a very
rural environment to have access to
uh wilderness got some muck boots for
people who
are looking for some bushwhacking boots
muck boots
are amazing sort of knee-high
boots that you can wear through mud and
anything you might want to
walk through they're not actually that
suffocatingly
hot for your feet so i'll throw those on
i'll throw on the
tick pants and just hike
for hours and there's so much land and
so much of the us that you
if you're able to move yourself
from point a to point b and there are a
lot of areas
outside of austin outside of a lot of
major cities la outside of new york city
where you can find space that has been
incredibly clearing for me i also
deleted all social
apps from my phone four weeks ago that's
crazy you know i did that a couple
months ago
yeah i did the same experiment and i
it's been fantastic
yeah i have i've i have missed exactly
nothing of great importance that i'm
aware of
meaning i talk to friends
i will occasionally on laptop
look at say
things that are trending on twitter that
might be relevant
to anything that i can affect positively
right
or areas where i can mitigate risks or
something like that but the vast
majority of news
is going to make you either anxious or
really pissed off
and if you're not prepared or able to
take action
on something that is within your sphere
of control
it's really just creating
energy leaks that will drain you
and i realized somewhere between i'd say
six and eight weeks ago
that i was extremely fatigued i was very
tired
and it was i think because i
had so many stimuli in the form of
different notifications or apps on my
phone social etc
which were creating these powerful
emotions
without any ability to direct them
towards
something positive and actionable does
that make sense
dude and so i've so i so i deleted them
from my phone
and talked to a lot of friends and
also will talk to members of my team you
know employees
uh we do team calls of various types
and feel like the signal to noise ratio
has improved so much
since i did that and i will occasionally
probably twice a week
look at at replies on twitter
because my listeners and readers are
extremely helpful
in helping me to find high
signal articles or research studies
that are really relevant to things they
know i care about and focus on
but outside of that it has been such a
freeing experience
and i really feel like social by and
large has been a huge net negative
dude it's so crazy that we came to the
same realization like uh
two a couple months ago i posted on
instagram
my like final post saying i'm not gonna
be on here for a while and the same
thing with twitter
and i removed all of them from my phone
all the apps from my phone
i and i stopped looking them all
together i
have not been on instagram since uh it's
been like you know
at least a couple months and i
have gone back on twitter because like
you
uh well two reasons one i some people
communicate me with them there over dm's
that i don't actually have their phone
number and so sometimes
there's important things that come
through and then also um
there is important stuff in terms of the
research i do for my job and investing
and on tech companies and all that like
it is a good source of that type of data
so but i still kept it off my phone
so it is a desktop only experience for
me now and i will tell you
you're right like the anxiety goes down
a ton the notifications to your device
goes down and you don't realize
you know what's funny i don't know if
you got this feeling but the first like
week i
was opening my phone up like oh i wonder
what's oh wait i don't have that app
anymore
did you like get that like like a few
times you're like oh wait a second i
don't i don't have that app
the other thing i did which you might
want to try this is kind of uh
and this is this is just dumb stuff
people are listening like don't like i'm
not trying to be holier than that when i
do this type of stuff it's just like
it's it's fun to do these little micro
experiments the other thing i did is i
said okay
how can i reduce the stress on my phone
even more and that would be
uninstalling even more garbage that i
don't use that might may or may not send
me notifications but
with every app there's like a micro
mental burden somewhere buried in there
of having just like one more thing to
check or one more thing that
is a potential uh distraction so i said
if i can't fit the apps
on the home page i'm not gonna have them
on my phone
so no swiping sideways for more apps so
basically i have one screen you just
have folders with like 75 apps and so i
do have folders but here's the rule with
the folders the folders cannot swipe
sideways
so i like only so that means a total of
nine apps and folders so basically this
is my
my home screen right here and so you can
see i just have the apps in there
it's not that many now the bottom the
reason people are looking at the bottom
the bottom
i do have a screen that goes sideways
that i put all the apple utilities and
crap that you kind of can't
uninstall like the compass app and the
measure app and the calculator and like
all that stuff
in its own little side folder thing but
what are the categories in those buckets
and those okay so here's what i have my
categories are
audio which means for me that's pocket
casts
music app and spotify audible sonos for
home stuff and pandora
so that's good health i have waking up i
have the strong app dexcom
aura less zero
uh for learning all the language
learning apps that i want to go back to
and uh lumosity and masterclass
and then finance stuff i have one screen
of that which is
you know personal capital financial
times wall street journal wealthfront
i like playing around with clarity money
and barons and simplify
and then i have home apps like home
control now home means like i got a
traeger barbecue which has been a
fantastic addition this summer by the
way
so i also got a trigger that's really
funny
yes yes which one did you get looks like
we're on uh
parallel tracks here uh the the one that
uh timberline 870 i got
the i actually did get the timberline
870 that's [ __ ] crazy that's the one
i got
i did get that and so i have
that in austin and at the undisclosed
rural location i have
i think it's a 650 so i got a slightly
smaller one because i looked at the 870
and i was like
okay maybe it is this expected it's like
you can cook you can cook
20 chickens at one time and i'm like i
don't need to cook 20 chickens at one
time so i got a smaller
smaller unit no i maybe i did get a
smaller unit as well
uh then you have me curious to see which
one i got it doesn't say on the app
right away i think it is the smaller of
the the timberline version but anyway
that's
that's a great one so last last one so
the home stuff has like things like that
where it's like
you know ring and lutron and that stuff
and to be clear
you have an app you have a traeger app
which helps you to control the grille so
you can check
the temperature and so on and so forth
yeah so we i just um by the way wild
salmon is running and it's on sale right
now but
it's it's i've been smoking salmon like
crazy
i've gone through six or seven different
recipes i finally found the perfect
smoked salmon that i'll i'll send you
which one on the trigger app that is
it's fantastic
but you got to let it cure 24 hours
that's the key you got to
you can't do any of these like little
rubs where you do like two or four hours
you got to do a full 24-hour cure on it
cool amazing i've been dialing in the
traeger like crazy
yeah i've been cooking uh a lot
period right we've been cooking a lot at
home
and cooking a lot of venison also
i don't know if i don't know if you even
know this kevin but
i ended up
you know you definitely know you can you
can confirm this i invest in very very
few things these days
and about a year ago i
invested in a venison harvesting
operation
in hawaii called the maui nui
venison for those people who are not
watching the video kevin is laughing
and really thought to myself there's no
way this is ever going to make any money
but i like the
ethos and the principles behind it
because
axis deer are an invasive species in
hawaii
they've destroyed a lot of ecosystem
they've damaged compromised coral reefs
because of runoff
after removing vegetation and
this operation harvests axis deer
and they they just approach it in such
a thoughtful
such a surgical way and
the meat is so incredibly good peter t
is obsessed with this also by the way
and which he and and he's the one in a
way who convinced me to combine the
traeger with this
this maui nui venison so the the leg
medallions are better for cooking
indoors but
rib racks steaks all of that are just
incredible and you've probably realized
this
on the trigger that one of the benefits
of having and for people who don't know
what the hell we're talking about this
is a
wood this is a wood pellet fueled
grill you could also think of it as a
smoker and in a lot of ways i tend to
think of it more as a smoker than a
grill because you're not going to get
it's it's more difficult to get say the
searing on a burger
in a tree yeah there's no direct direct
flame that's right
but but if you cook ribs at super low
temperature
like 165 or 185
you just get the most incredible flavor
oh yeah
i did i did ribs last night i did some
heritage pork ribs
by the way speaking of trading uh like
places to buy meat
um have you used crowd cow at all i've
not
used crowd cow you know there are a
couple of these companies i have used
butcher box
which might be similar i i'm not sure i
don't know crowd cow yeah so crowd cow
is essentially what they've said is like
okay there are
you know a dozen or so probably more
amazing farms in the united states that
are these like small
little tiny mom and pop farms they don't
really have way to get
proper distribution online first of all
they don't even know how to set up their
own online
you know site and so let's go to them
and
and put them on our site and it's only
like
the best small little amazingly run
farms and also they work with japanese
farmers as well
so they get in some of the best wagyu
that i've ever had
a5 um certified with all the holograms
and everything on there and they work
with a couple really small farms out
there
and that that's fun stuff so do you
choose
you then choose the farms you want to
buy the me from you pick individually
yeah so you can do it i think how they
started
was like you had to kind of put together
a portion of a cow
like x number of pieces and then you
would save like you're going in on a cow
now it's like all i think that's a
feature in there somewhere but now it's
like all a la carte now so you can just
go
i just want some amazing rib eyes or i
want a rack and like they're just right
there
ready to buy cool yeah butcher box kind
of mixes and matches and you get
a membership so i have
pork and beef from them as well another
one
that is close to our long ago
home in norcal is belcampo i don't know
if you've tried any of their stuff
now belcampo has incredible rib eyes
so those those are the two non-venison
sources that i've i've been trying these
days
but that's that's about it uh
as far as as miko's i've tried to really
do a uh take out less as not less is
more but like if you're gonna eat meat
like
really do it in as thoughtful way
as possible which i recognize
is in a sense a luxury right i mean it
it is
uh because we have the the means to sort
of explore some of these options and
some of them aren't cheap
certainly triggers aren't cheap um
triggers aren't that expensive man they
make ones that are
further down the line that aren't the
fancy fancy ones
that actually do a great job smoking my
buddy has one of the ones you can buy at
costco
and it is it's it's phenomenal and
they're they're not they're not crazy i
mean they're not cheap but they're not
crazy crazy they're not talking
thousands of dollars or anything you
know
yeah so so i've been enjoying
really paying attention to the
fundamentals for me just
hearkening back to what you said about
us being in a pretty
bad place stressed out place i mean i
was in a very anxious
stressed out place for a really long
time
once i kind of saw the the the comet
of covid headed towards you know planet
earth
united states since early february right
so i've had this low grade or high grade
anxiety
for months and eventually you just get
[ __ ] tired of the
anxiety so you want to figure out
approaches to
to lessen it and for me it's
it's really been keep it simple stupid
right
eat good food cook food take time to
prep it's super meditative
if you're using a sharp knife you got to
pay attention or you're going to
chop your little pretty fingers off
and i've been doing hrv training so
heart rate variability training with
breath work
and it's the jury's still out i've been
doing that for five weeks
twice a day for 20 minutes can i ask
what that practice looks like
yeah it looks like using an app i'm
using one called breath or actually it
has a very generic
name but this is not to imply that it's
the best app out there but it's still on
breathing
it's just called breathing and it's a
circle that opens and contracts
to help you time the duration of your
inhale and exhale
what is it what is the um the you know
sometimes there's the four seven eight
breath there's five and a half seconds
this one is i think i'm doing
3.7 second inhale and
6.3 second exhale and i arrived at that
or i didn't
i'm working with a doctor i i don't want
to mention her name just yet but i'm
working with
a phd who sent me a kit
which includes a pulse oximeter which
you put on your thumb
to track your pulse and
[Music]
heart rate and and then blood ox as well
right and blood ox
although i think we're looking less at
that and then a
a respiration strap so it looks like
basically a bra that you put on
uh under your nip nips and uh what would
be
just above your navel and as you breathe
and it expands there are sensors
that track that and so you can
correlate and superimpose your breathing
on your heart rate
and she would then take me through
we would use zoom share screen and she
would take me through different
exercises to identify
which duration of inhale and exhale
seemed optimal for me in terms of
activating my
sympathetic i'm sorry my parasympathetic
nervous system so more more of a
autonomous relaxation response and if
people have trouble
separating the two so sympathetic you
can think of stimulating
s equals stimulating sympathetic like
fight or flight
fight flight freeze it's not quite that
simple but it's a
useful shorthand and then
parasympathetic would be
uh more of the letting go calming and
i have incredible hyper vigilance i mean
i don't think we're going to get into it
today but it's a lot of
gnarly stuff happened to me as a kid and
my system
well as she would put it i am cardiac
hyper reactive
so little things will send my heart rate
shooting to the ceiling and then my
heart rate will stay elevated for hours
and and that's part of the reason
to the tune of what like what 90 beats a
minute like
not crazy yeah 80 to 80 to 90. but
that's i mean
if we're talking like six seven hours
that's a long time no i was worried
you're going to tell me something worse
but yeah that is that is
that's like you know that you probably
should be walking the dog at that rate
you know what i mean like that's
not just sitting there that is elevated
yeah
and your fatigue has been this
lifelong battle of mine since i would
say
age 16 17 especially with lyme disease
on long island and all these undiagnosed
lyme and then later diagnosed which is
how
now the people are familiar with
serologic testing
you know i i was tested with when i when
i was suffering acute symptoms and they
said well you're positive
for the short-term antibodies but you
realize you've already had lyme disease
because you're testing positive
for the long term as well and
uh so i've really tried in
the last my dog's pacing all over the
place you can
you can see where is she where are you
molly hiding behind me there she is
kind of see her but i think she has to
pee i might have to take a little break
to let her out
but uh
long story short this this fatigue is
like my battle
right it's like without sufficient
energy you you really can't execute well
on anything else
and by execute well i would include like
relaxing and enjoying yourself
right yeah if the tank is empty the tank
is empty so
the fundamentals the food the
hrv slash meditation all these things
have been
focused on identifying
like cracks in the vessel where i'm
leaking
energy and so a lot of those
i've found to be really helpful right
like the jumping rope i'm not talking
about like 10 rounds of jumping rope i'm
not
mike tyson getting back into shape to to
try to lop
roy jones jr's head off i'm talking
about like three to five minutes jumping
rope
first thing in the morning just to get
outside to make sure i get outside
into some sun ideally and move my body
that's it and if people are interested
in the
the intersection and the interplay
between
exercise and the brain
and brain health and brain neurotrophic
or
brain derived neurotrophic factors yeah
bdnf
there's a book called spark that gets
into this but if you want to get out of
your
monkey mind at least for me one of the
fastest ways
is through the body and it doesn't take
a lot it really doesn't take a lot get
outside
walk for a few minutes jump rope for
three to five minutes and then go back
inside so those are a few things i've
been doing i don't know if you found any
routines or other practices helpful yeah
you know it's it's funny
i've just now recently started getting
back into meditation
but in a in a different way you know
before
i had done um sam's course you know
which i think that
you've done as well uh harris is waking
up app
so are you still doing the tantric
self-pleasuring meditation that you told
me about
the one that you zoom with me on yeah
we're still doing that wednesdays
every tuesday exactly
um no no this is uh it's interesting i i
was
um i was on sam's app and this was uh
several weeks ago and i
saw that there was a new course on there
by henry shukman who is a
he practices a certain lineage of zen
and he's based out of um
uh where is he based off not arizona but
um new mexico
and he just had these beautiful
10-minute meditations on these zen coans
do you know much about
zen coans yeah yeah paradoxical
sort of statements or parables that are
intended to
as i understand it intended to derail
the rational mind right
to right sort of sideline the rational
mind so like what is the sound of one
hand clapping type of stuff
right and they they're these beautiful
little
uh unsolvable riddles you know that that
that that are part of the practice and
that they will meditate
with them and on them um and
then take back their kind of insights
that are gathered from these
uh over time back to their teachers and
it's kind of like a
uh you know you talk them through with
your teacher there is no real
answer to them but they're used as
they're very difficult to
describe but they're they're used as a
part of the the zen training
and so i had was very fortunate to reach
out to sam and sam introduced me to
henry
and henry um has since come on my
podcast
and he had a a book that
um he recently published called one
blade of grass um by henry shukman i'm
just pulling it up right now it's on
amazon
fantastic book that talks about
it's basically a biography of his life
and he talks about all the struggles
that he faced
he had severe eczema all over his body
where he was like hospitalized
bleeding knuckles like really bad for
for decades
how do you spell his last name uh his
last name is spelled
s-h-u-k-m-a-n got it
thanks and so yeah he's a he's this
fantastic zen master and i
i i um i read his book and he talks
about
his path to these stages of
enlightenment
and how he was able to
slowly over time he was one of these
people that had a very early
experience and didn't even know how to
put into words what had happened to him
because he wasn't training at the time
and then later went into zen and had
other
experiences and then all the way through
to today
where he describes the falling away of
basically of everything the the the just
everything
falls away at some point uh during this
training and it's a beautiful story on
zen
and really just um re-emphasized to me
that
that i mean he's he's you know had a
career as a writer and he was uh
an award-winning poet and you know
oxford trained
um very busy productive human
wife two children and has still been
able to go off and obtain
these uh very deep life
uh well he's now kind of flipped onto
the side of
the they're lasting now the changes are
lasting versus going back to
reality after a couple weeks um
fascinating story but also
just one where i i by the end of the
book i was like i need to get back into
zen like
because i i don't i've told you at some
point you knew i you used to come to my
house when i live right next to the zen
center
but my my first training uh in san
francisco was at that zen center
um and then i i fell away from it
because i didn't
really take it seriously but uh yeah so
henry's gonna
help me really get back into zen and
he's uh i'm
i'm excited to to go to he has the
mountain cloud zen center that he runs
and uh i'm gonna be taking some courses
there and i really want to take this
seriously i figure
i'm in my 40s now it's time to devote a
decent percentage of my life to this
type of training like i i feel like it's
it's time
i'd love to hear you elaborate on that
because i know you've you've tried all
sorts of different
types of meditation i'm still
interested to know if you
recommend the surrender course
by i do michael singer michael singer
but you you have you've explored these
various tools and modalities what is it
about zen
that differentiates it for you or that
you find attractive right because you
could
you could reach out to or get a hold of
your one of your
magic powers is getting getting hold of
anybody
basically you want to get a hold of why
zen what is it
i would say that when i first took my
that when i first took the introductory
course to zen
i appreciated
the mystery behind it in some sense so i
was attracted to
how it could be a
strict discipline in in some ways like
you know like kind of one of these
things where you show up for zazen and
if you're not there the second you're
supposed to be there they'll keep you up
from coming in
and you're rejected or if you want to
train and actually set up a residence
there like
you have to prove it by sleeping outside
for like two months like all these
stories that you hear that
henry actually talks about it can be
super hardcore or
like you let you go to the zazen uh
room and you're you're separated by
these like cubicle walls
right and so you're you're sitting in
zazen this like seated meditation with
your face about a foot and a half
away from a wooden wall and then if you
start to nod off they might
hit you with a little wooden switch
right exactly
yeah so you know i i kind of i was
initially attracted that now henry's
discipline
that he's into uh that he's teaching is
is a little bit more laid back which i
which i can appreciate because this is
like you know when you're going to to
you had to enter with your right foot
when you're entering into
to sit like you have to enter into the
room the correct way
you can't cross over the mat in the
wrong way like there's all these rules
right
too many roles but it's also very
japanese
but i i it is very japanese which i you
know we all both of us
really love um but the one thing i will
say about zen
and is that in a especially with the way
that henry's been
teaching at least that i gathered
through his book and and through our
conversation
is that they're they make
enlightenment less mysterious and less
about being
a perfect person and making it actually
seem like it's something that is
attainable
by everyone and it doesn't have to mean
that you're this ultimate spiritual guru
the second you snap into these different
states of consciousness and that there
are these
really beautiful moments when people
have this flip
like this flip in their brain the switch
that goes and then they're they're
jolted almost shocked
into this this state of consciousness
like sometimes like there's these
stories of these zen masters well
they'll look at a student the right way
and
the student won't grasp it and the
student can't they've been stu
they've been teaching and sitting and
they just can't and they'll just shake
them in a certain way and it'll
spontaneously jolt them in the right way
into enlightenment
and there's these these funky little
things like that that are just like
beautiful stories and like you know you
always take a lot of that stuff with a
grain of salt but
coupled with this coan training which i
which i highly recommend
listening to on on the waking up app
they're fantastic by henry
um it it just it's it checks all
the boxes that i'm curious about and i
think for me
the curiosity at this point is the most
important thing
because it's encouraging me and it gives
me the drive to go and sit for a half
hour every morning
consistently and you know that's what
it's going to take it's going to take a
real dedication
and i i think that if i can get the
proper uh
training coupled with these cohens and i
i don't know
just i i've done the transcendental
meditation i've done a few other
disciplines and
this one for some reason um maybe it's
because i'm a japanophile like i don't
know
all the reasons but i'm attracted to it
cool
do you know what the training is going
to look like and what the meditation
sessions are going to look like yeah i
mean
they're very simple you just sit so it's
it's like
what i'm more interested in what hap
what happens inside the head so you sit
maybe you shave your head i would love
to see you the shaved head that'd be
hilarious
uh so like kind of thing yeah we can we
can
be cue balls together uh get you some
black robes with some
some white inner linings be good good
luck for you uh you kind of already have
that look you gotta
say you see we've been in robes together
in japan
you already got that one aced but okay
you sit and then what what happens on
the inside
so i think there's there's a few things
one um
the question initially is there is
there's kind of table stakes to to play
in the arena and i would say
like to even get to that point
um at least for for me when i've what
i've been told and what i can gather and
i'm i'm saying this is someone that is
uh
well pretty new novice to this new
sect of zen um it's just sitting
and trying to quiet the mind you know
and that means counting meditations
um you know counting to 10 and repeating
yourself following the breath
uh it's it's that classic zen posture
of looking at the wall not closing your
eyes kind of glancing
somewhat downward towards the ground
with a
fuzzy awareness of everything going on
in the room but no strict focus on any
one object
it's saying to yourself a thought a
distraction
it's okay it is uh the weights in a gym
is what i need to get to the next like
level of
of this and so not getting upset and
and getting the mind to where it's a
little bit malleable
and kind of getting to that place where
this the sits are becoming
longer in duration but also the mind is
calming down a bit i think
henry said it best in his book actually
this is a i'm going to butcher it but
i'll
i'll tell you the gist of it he said the
zen
is like pulling the plug
being a a boat in a bathtub and pulling
the plug of the drain
and initially you kind of just notice a
little bit of swirling
a little bit of like movement of the
boat and then you look around
and you see the walls of the bathtub are
a little bit higher and you're like oh
that's odd
and then you notice a little bit more
movement and all of a sudden
you start to twist and then all of a
sudden you notice that there's a swirl
going down the drain
and then there is the total annihilation
of all things and that's where you're
headed
but you don't but you have to sit at the
surface for a while
and just kind of like you know slowly
realize that even though you're not
feeling it
the daily practice is unplugging the
drain and and you will eventually get
there
so i'm never fine that's a terrifying
description oh dude wait till you read
his book
his description of his last tranche of
this passing into this i think you would
actually really like it because it
reminds me of a lot of our conversations
that you have had
around like ayahuasca and some of the
ego uh
just disintegrating and controlled death
control death
and he's getting that without any drugs
man just like intense
like multi-day meditation kind of things
that that happen
you know for for i guess a lot of
reasons i think that scares me more
because with with the tea you're like
all right i'm gonna go to crazy town
for four to six hours earth time
and then i'll be back to some semblance
of like normal
computation and absorption of what we
call
reality but with the zen practice with
that description it's
it's almost like a slow-motion
psychotic break that you've engineered
for yourself and that scares the living
[ __ ] out of me
so that's i don't know how to back out
of that i don't know how to
yeah you can't you can't that's the
thing that's crazy dude
when you read this book and you get to
that point i'm
freaked out by this because when you go
there
all of a sudden you're viewing the world
as an illusion as a completely different
thing than you ever have before and
there's no going back
what does daria think about this is she
supportive
yeah she listened to my interview with
him when i did the podcast and she was
like yeah he sounds amazing and this is
this is the path you want to go like i i
support it i mean i i don't think
she's not worried about you like
i don't know wearing your shirt
backwards and picking at naval lint like
staring blankly at like the wall
you have to you ha you have to listen to
his post analysis of
what happened because he wrote the book
after all this happened
and i'm curious to know if you would
enjoy this world i think you would it
sounds
beautiful like every moment is
anew and just glistening and
there's so much it's fascinating i'm
gonna butcher it all
i think much like you with me and my
various
uh psychedelic experiments of which
there are now
many many many many let me think for you
it's a lot and uh you've kind of let me
be the guinea pig i think i'll let you
be the first monkey shot into space on
this
slow-motion engineered psychotic break
tell me how that goes yeah i mean that's
here to support
i i think well it's not like you're
gonna see me in six months and like
we're i'm just gonna be
levitating like this is going to be like
a if i do it correctly
this is going to be like a 30-year kind
of journey you know to get to these
these places or you know who knows
there's no there's no pinning a
date unless you unless he like grabs you
by your ears and shakes your head and
gives you the
highlander quickening like you were
describing i'd love that actually
grab you by your eyebrows and bite your
[ __ ] upper lip and like
throw your throw you off your chair
[Laughter]
that's exciting yeah you should you
should check out his book
one blade of grass i highly recommend it
to anyone listening it's it's a fun
audible he has a fantastic
uh you know british voice he's from the
uk so his uh his audiobook is
is fun is a fun lesson
you know yeah the the british accent
gives you an automatic
plus 20 points of iq oh 100
at least for um at least for any yanks
listening to it my god
such a such an upgrade uh you know i
wanted to
to thank you for something you
introduced me to actually uh because
i've been
consuming a ton of it you remember when
you gave me some
peak uh the
yes the p-i-q-u-e for anyone
wondering not inexpensive
but they're powdered poo air i've
actually been
having almost every morning for the last
while
and it's fantastic i've been having that
usually before
i do so the sequence for me would be
wake up immediately do the
breathwork hrv meditation for 20 minutes
then heat the water to like
170 uh pretty low temperature just
because i
i don't like continually burning the
[ __ ] out of my mouth when i forget how
hot something is in an insulated mug
and then putting in the peak uh poo air
with i don't know if you've ever tried
layered superfood creamer the
unsweetened stuff
it's basically powdered mct oil is one
way to think about it
and i've been fasting well
if people consider it fasting i've been
semi-fasting until
late lunch a lot recently and so i'll
have
that and then go into the say
jump rope and so on but uh the peak is
uh it's really good it took me a while
to get into but
i appreciate you introducing me to that
it's funny because um
i i i never know like sometimes i'll
reach out to you like
every time you plug me as someone that
can get you stuff
on your on podcasts and stuff like that
all of a sudden when do i plug you
like well every once in a while we'll do
a podcast together and you'll be like oh
dude thanks for that recommendation
and then like a week later a hundred
random emails
hey i have this like ball massager can
you give it to tim like
he would love it blah blah i'm just like
everybody
comes out like it's and so i'm i'm like
you're like
basically i try all the [ __ ] and the
good stuff i pass on to you so
i appreciate you the peak is a
cool company i met with um with with the
founder and
we were chatting about um how he creates
some of this stuff because they
the thing that's unique about it is that
you know so many times like tea
as you know is like you steep it and you
discard the leaves when you're done
they um steep it crystallize it
through this like crazy process and then
they make it instant so it's like you
can just pour it in you don't have to
think about it you don't have to think
about steeping it it's like if you took
every t and made it into matcha right
right exactly basically yeah and so it's
uh
it's really easy to consume and you
can't screw it up which is a lot of
people will receive their tea and
they're like a t is so bitter it's so
you know and it's like no
it's not weird and astringent it's just
that you've oversteeped it that's the
main
complaint um but anyway yeah it's
awesome yeah they they do
they do quality stuff i'm glad you got
i'm glad you're enjoying it
yeah what uh what else is what else is
new in your world man
oh gosh i would say
new stuff that i'm into um
well i've got boring stuff like i'm
getting into salmon fishing that's gonna
be next oh i've got one
i've got one uh i don't you're the app
guy
i'm the idiot who's like you know in in
2022 i'm like i found this app called
whatsapp it's really great and you're
like oh boy here we go
yeah so i am i'm pretty slow on the
uptake
when it comes to apps but i did find one
because
i was i as i mentioned
doing a lot of hiking have been doing a
lot of hiking
and uh i'm in a very rural area i don't
want to wander onto somebody's property
and have somebody like come outside of
the shotgun and be like hey
what the hell are you doing on my
property and i also just want to be
respectful right i don't want people
showing up at my house but i i
really wasn't sure how to identify
property boundaries
and i've i met someone
who hunts locally and introduced me to
something called the on
x hunting app and it's just
o on x and on x
hunt is the app and i'm not going to
necessarily use this for hunting
but what it allows you to do and they
give you the premium features for free
for seven days which is
super super smart if if they're actually
listening to this
i would i think they would get such
better conversion
and probably increase their revenue
forty fifty percent at least from this
particular app if they had an onboarding
process
which they don't right there's no
automatic tutorial that i saw which
meant i had to kind of fumble and go
find online faqs and
figure it out but the onyx hunt app
allows you to see property boundaries it
allows you to hit
track and track yourself as you hike
so maybe similar to a strava in that
sense
but in this particular case it's for
it's for
wilderness you can save maps offline
so you can use them when you don't have
reception you can look at
topographical view satellite view or
combinations
you can take photographs so for instance
if i find something of interest
uh and i want to share that with someone
i can take a photograph
geotag it and then just share it with
someone else who's on the app
and it's cool right now it actually it
also covers phishing as well which is
great yeah it's a it's a
it's a it's an extremely extremely cool
app
so i've uh been using that on a
pretty much daily basis in it and
really really enjoying it who knows
maybe i will use it for hunting i don't
hunt much i do it pretty infrequently
but
if i were to travel to say hawaii to
hunt axis deer which maybe at some point
i will
it's not not particularly easy to do i
don't even know if i could get
permission to do it but
i would use something like this so that
i could see how much mileage i'm
covering
where i was where i went perhaps
we go on a scouting trip
during non-hunt hours or on a non-hunt
day and i could take photographs of
particular locations that i think
might be ideal and save those and then i
can
go back and review that so i've been
i've been loving it that's that's
that's an app that might not otherwise
come across your radar that
uh you might get a kick out of playing
with it's cool yeah it looks awesome
i'll definitely give that a shot given
how many hiking trails are here
uh you know in portland there's just so
many hundreds of miles of hiking trails
just right
in the city which is crazy yeah um so
i you asked me what i'm into lately
actually i do have one thing i haven't
told you about
um you know i've been
i think that lately i've put on some
weight
and i have been able to shut it back off
through intermittent fasting
um and then also you know doing a lot of
cardio and things like that but
how do you typically what's what's your
intermittent fasting look like just real
quick
uh 18 hours a day if i'm in if i'm in
lean mode like if i want to get lean
18 hours a day if not at a minimum 14
i think that's when a lot of the the
data i have a
a friend uh out of the uc san diego she
works with
longo out there and she said that the i
was just talking to her like a week ago
and she said
14 hours is what she does and that's
where a lot of the data looks really
promising in terms of just like some of
the longevity benefits
i think you're gonna do it every single
day eating from what like
between what hour and whatever well i
just basically when i use zero obviously
uh
and uh you know when i when i'm done
eating dinner so
it's you are with the kids and putting
them down and all that stuff you never
know when you're gonna actually finish
your last bite so whenever i'm done
i just hit start and whenever you know
it tells me to eat it again then i
then i eat um okay but it's 14 hours
after i finish my last bite basically
yeah cool and so what i'm doing 18 hours
you know sometimes i'm eating a late
dinner and like that i'm not eating
until 1 30 2 o'clock the next day
you know which is which is a little
brutal but it's okay i just have black
coffee and i'm totally fine
um but to to uh i actually
the point i was gonna or what i was
gonna chat about is that
in choosing my alcohol and alcohol
consumption especially during
covet there was like this period there
where like march
april i was like we're all going to die
i'm just going to get drunk the entire
time you know i'm just going
i remember that every time i talk to you
you're like hey
says whatever i'm five glasses in how
the [ __ ] are you i'm like i didn't say
i didn't say five glasses but i was
definitely three you know it's like
but it was you know we were we didn't
know what was gonna happen and it was
kind of freaky and it's like might as
well
open the good stuff you know yeah so um
in
in my cutting back
and focusing more on health what i've
decided to do
and this is kind of a crazy thing is
like okay wine can get nutso like
a really nice bottle of wine can be
thousands of dollars for like crazy
wines right like
nobody wants to do that i mean some
people i guess won't do that but not on
a regular basis
so what i was thinking is why not go
i went to beer advocate and i went to
their top 100 beers
and i've been slowly finding and buying
the
top 10 rated beers in the world and then
trying them
like just to consume like have you ever
had the number one rated beer in the
world i hadn't
it's right here it's uh it's called the
um kentucky
breakfast stout and it is uh
from topping toppling goliath here let
me show you what it looks like one sec
since we have video
all right so out of the the top uh beers
of the world i would say out of the top
ten
um probably seven or eight of them are
stouts
so it's like the thick dark rich
funky slow sip type stuff
so so look at the smelt on the top of
that that's cool
now who they're hand numbered 233 so
you said beer advocate i know nothing
about beer
so beer advocates like their top just
like some guy
named tony in newark new jersey is right
now i think it's community based and
and they they have a lot of a lot of the
pros and stuff go on there that are
really into this but but this kentucky
brunch
stout by toppling goliath it's so the
vintage is 2016 so they age these like
wine
because they are so dense you can just
basically put them
uh in you know the wine cellar and let
them sit for a decade or longer
and then they really mellow out over
time um
so i just i picked this up i found it i
found a great site actually by the way
i'm giving away all my
best links but people need to know about
this because it's a fantastic site
my favorite place to buy aftermarket
beer and i've done a lot of research on
this
uh is mybeercollectables.com
so now you say aftermarket it makes it
sound like you're buying a spoiler for
your
miata or something what does that mean
so what that means is
you know this is bottle number 233 maybe
they made 500 bottles in this year
so it's impossible to find you can't buy
it new you just can't buy
i got it so the site you mentioned is
like the ebay
exactly it's the ebay beer and so you
can get pliny the elder on there
this one i got on there too this is
called the sr-71 by the same
manufacturer
this one's ranked i think number 12 or
something like that it's got you can't
see but there's like a little blackbird
stealth bomber on there
uh or not itself but it's a sr-71
actually and then all the ingredients
and everything are written in binary on
the side
these are so cool they're like culty
little fun beers so
you you gave a price anchor on the wines
right
thousands of dollars you can go i mean
tens of thousands probably hundreds of
thousands right i mean get
wine get super super crazy so what what
does
one of these very well-ranked
beers go okay so let me give you it's
wide-ranging
so for example i got um some of them
that can't be aged you have to drink
them fresh so like there's a
the number one ranked ipa or i think
it's the number two ranked ipa in the
world is called
um the julius by a brand called
treehouse okay
so the julius king julius by treehouse
right now a four pack
on this site is going for 39.99 and
that's the number one
or number two ranked uh ipa in the world
that's so cool what was the name of the
site again that you mentioned
mybeercollectables.com that's such a
great
url yeah it's like it's such a janky
site but like they've got a lot of great
great beers on here it's on geocities
that's cool that's super cool yeah the
the affordable vices right there are
certain things
where you can get the best in the
country or the best in the world
for less than 50 bucks right i mean
there are
certain categories of thing where you
can go very high-end i mean
i think really good chocolate would be
an example of that
right if you really wanted to have a
treat i mean you don't
necessarily have to break the bank to do
that but if you're like oh i want to get
the fanciest car the fanciest boat the
fanciest wine i mean
you better have in inexhaustible funds
or you're screwed
uh and you know at the end of the day if
you think about it too it's like that
stuff
ages really poorly right yeah
those types of neither of us collect
that kind of stuff but
if if you if you think of we know people
who do
and it's like four weeks after they've
bought
something it loses its luster
for most and uh instead if you have this
uh in the cases we're talking about
right the beer or the chocolate there's
a
there's something really special about
the perishable nature of it
and it's it's an experience
right well that's the key right it's an
experience like that's what's been
linked to happiness is like actually
having
experiences with friends and like this
is sharing something like that right
yeah it's great cool love it
i love it oh i i don't i don't have
anything
i don't have any big ones on my on my
list or anything that's coming to mind
one thing i want to ask you before we
wrap uh yeah i don't know if you'll
share this actually
uh you may not we might have to cut it
but um what are you
so the stock market is so freaking crazy
right now
yeah it is gold is going up and
individual stocks are going up and i'm
like well
yeah that doesn't make sense like what
are you
doing like what's the tim ferriss uh
four-hour finance
uh version of this
oh boy yeah be careful everybody
earmuffs earmuffs cover your ears
uh i'll tell you what i've
i can tell you what i've done yeah what
are you doing and
and it's not so much doing it's more
what i've done
and i'm glad you asked this because i
recently turned 43
and a while back i
spoke with my parents looked at the
genealogy asked a lot of questions and
determined that the average age of death
of males
on both sides of my family if you adjust
for some outliers
is 85 so 43 puts me past
the half mile mark right and hopefully i
live until 120 but i've also
lived aggressively right so my system's
taken a beating
and i don't assume i'm gonna live that
long
so i've been doing a lot of
introspection and this birthday hit me
kind of hard usually age i'm just like
ah whatever it doesn't matter
but crossing past that 50
mark hit me unusually
and i've been doing a lot of journaling
a lot of thinking and
i realized that number one and you've
seen this over the years like i don't
have
a high burn lifestyle right like i don't
i don't buy
lots of stuff uh and
like if i have a the ability to hike
with my dog
my dog and my girlfriend are happy and
healthy and
you know occasionally i'll splurge on
nice food or something but i don't i
don't really
you're not a flashy guy like i've never
seen you with a sports car i've never
seen you with
a fancy watch i've seen you with fancy
horse saddles
that's the only thing i've seen yet it's
true that's true the only that was like
probably the first time i ever splurged
people think that he's joking he's not
actually joking so for the
for the four hour body because i killed
myself
on that book in more ways than one and i
was super proud of it and i made a
promise to myself because i very rarely
celebrated
and that's that's been a weakness of
mine as i don't celebrate
right i'm very hard on myself and i feel
like you become
well the story i've told myself for a
long time is you become complacent if
you
over congratulate yourself so i tend to
really not pause and smell the roses so
to speak
not you guys the other roses and
smell you guys too though and
and so celebrate has been this
this kind of word of the year for many
years for me
and when i finished writing the
four-hour body i
promised myself if it hit number one new
york times
that i would [ __ ] saddles well
i didn't think about the horsehouse
specifically but i said i'll get
something special for myself that
relates to japan because i used to live
in japan i have this
deep love for for japan and the japanese
people
and i had
around the same time maybe a little bit
afterwards you might remember this
i did a tv show
pilot where i went to japan and
attempted to learn
horseback archery in one week and i'm
pretty sure you can find it online if
you go on youtube and search trial by
fire you might be able to find it
it's wild and it's [ __ ] dangerous as
hell so i did that
and i had i had been thinking maybe i'll
get a sword maybe i'll get some type of
armor
and then i thought to myself actually
because i had this experience i'd really
like to
to get either saddle or stirrups of some
type
initially i was just looking for
stirrups because i thought they'd be
cheaper and just easier to
deal with and ended up finding a
beautiful
wooden carved saddle so i do have a
japanese saddle
which at the end of the day wasn't that
expensive but for me it was it was
like the one of the first times i've
ever treated myself to anything
so yes aside from all that and so to to
zoom out
back to the the question about investing
i realized when i was journaling
around my birthday that uh thinking
about
money generally does not make me happy
it makes me more anxious
and at the same time
i feel like i'm pretty good at because
i'm hyper analytical and over analytical
you might say like i'm pretty good at
fussing around and optimizing but the
the optimizing at this point in my life
i figured out a lot of things that make
me happy i figured out a lot of things
that don't make me happy
and most of the things that make me
happy don't require a lot of capital so
this is just a long way of saying i
decided that
i wanted to make all of my investing
decisions
or like money decisions uh
by my birthday it didn't quite work out
so i gave myself a grace period
to uh
to the first of august and then to take
a six to 12 month break
on all of that stuff meaning like i'm
not allowed to
consider new deals i'm not allowed to
look at stocks i'm not allowed to do any
of that stuff and
uh so now i'm glad i'm saying it
publicly because i want to make myself
accountable
uh so i'll tell you what i did uh it's
pretty simple
uh i've i've thought about and it's been
made
more complex as you said because it's
alice in wonderland
in the markets right now like stuff is
happening that just
by any kind of rational prediction
pre-covet just should not be happening
there's all sorts of weird stuff and
then
i'm not sure what's happening right now
but certainly previously you had the the
fed
buying high-yield bonds like all this
stuff that
was off the playbook and
that there's such a dislocation between
the market
and the economic reality of millions of
people in the united states
i mean tens of millions for the entire
entire
country for that matter that
i i only wanted to put money in places
where i felt i had some informational
advantage
or not just in my head but like in my
heart and
gut just had some conviction that i
couldn't quite explain
does that make sense or i'm just like
this feels like it makes all the sense
in the world
and i don't have that very much so just
to be clear to people i'm not one of
those people who
uh uses the word intuition as
justification for lots of haphazard [ __ ]
that's just not me
uh but you know you and i
i think is a way honestly to kind of
distract us from the stress and
uncertainty
at least in my case like talked about
quite a bit of investing stuff over the
last few months but we haven't talked in
maybe the last
i don't know two months about this stuff
and
you know you had some predictions uh
that i think turned out
really well i don't know if you're open
to talking about them but like peloton
right
where i thought maybe that was already
baked in so i was like ah
you know like i'm not gonna buy a bunch
of different things from peloton i don't
have enough room
i do have one bike and i love the bike
but i'm not gonna buy a bunch
they've ended up doing really well at
least last i saw so
the the question i asked myself was
which companies if we're talking about
the stock market right because
i don't think it helps people if we talk
about more esoteric stuff like
distressed debt
or you know spax or
like weird stuff that most people aren't
gonna have access to but when i looked
at the stock market because my biggest
uh i would say my most my highest
conviction bets
have been in the in the stock market
which you know
is crazy for me i don't play in that
sandbox you do that all the time
uh but i i i just asked myself like
this was around
mid-march and i listened to an interview
with chamath i can never say his last
name
but uh interview on investing and sort
of his
framework for looking at different
investments and it it catalyzed a bunch
of questions for me
some were the same questions he had
listed out i put i put this interview
in five bullet friday the newsletter
that i put out so
um i think the interviewer
was pomp is this nickname or pompeono
i think we both talked about this
podcast together maybe i sent it to you
i don't know
you might have said to me there's a very
good chance that you sent it to me
i mean this is the kind of thing that
you would send to me so everybody
listening send your interviews to kevin
and i began to wonder
which companies technology companies
would do extremely well
if kovid were protracted
or if covert were somehow magically
resolved in three months like which
companies would benefit from
a short period of
dramatic online acceleration
even if it ended in three months and
especially if it continued for a year
year and a half
uh and at the same time i was i was
looking closely at other countries like
china where i might be getting the
numbers wrong but
there's something like 79 all e-commerce
and we're
17 something like that and
this is a lot of money a lot of room to
grow and i wasn't trying to do any fancy
spreadsheet analysis and i know people
are going to say well then you're
speculating
then there might be some truth to that
but i only
really considered a handful of companies
and i ended up deciding this is when
uh and i can tell you what the prices
were too so amazon at about 2
000 and shopify
at about 380 per share
and this would have been in very i want
to say early
april but some point in april and i
decided
to initially i was looking at a bunch of
different companies and what i
decided for myself was that if i if if i
was
dividing my bets because i had low
conviction
i shouldn't put money into any of those
bets
and i'm not saying that's the right
approach but that logic made sense to me
and i said all right
i have high conviction around amazon and
shopify and
if one dominates the other then you know
perhaps i still break even right
but what i noticed was when i went i use
amazon
all the time and certainly my spending
has increased dramatically
after covid and i remember when
amazon was limited to essential goods
and i couldn't get anything else
right i would go to order like coffee
filters and it was like four-week
delivery
and i thought to myself these companies
are [ __ ]
right like if if these people are
are largely dependent on amazon and they
don't have
a an elegant or effective
e-commerce plan b they're going to need
to do that immediately
and who's that going to be and as
somebody who isn't
you know one of the first advisors to to
shopify and then
uh one could argue stupidly but it made
sense to me at the time i ended up
selling shortly after lock-up period
when they ipo'd so i became an advisor
and they had eight to
12 employees now they have whatever two
thousand
uh i always kicked myself right because
i love those guys
and they know what they're doing they're
good guys
the they're very strategically
intelligent they're great at executing
so i was always kind of kicking myself
and i and and when they suspended
their guidance for 2020 and they got
pummeled i just thought to myself
all right you know if you really believe
that
and you're seeing this kind of trend
then this would be the time to like push
some serious chips in
and it's like either put in enough where
if it grows like and i kind of
in my mind thought okay two to three x
in share price over the next three years
did not expect it to happen in three
months i mean that's just bonkers
right yeah uh but those are the only
those are the only if i
i don't think i'm omitting anything but
i think those are the the two stocks
that that i put a lot into but it was
really thinking about
what would do well no matter what
and of course there are lots of unknowns
there's
there's a key person risk in both of
these companies but
they've they've both been really really
smart and i
i don't know about you i think you do
this too i mean i base a lot of my
investment decisions this is true for
early stage
and it's also true for later stage just
based on my personal day-to-day
experiences
and yeah how i'm spending money and how
my behaviors are changing
and if i see those same behaviors
changing in a dozen of my friends i'm
like
i think this is the thing well i mean
that's that's the beauty of being an
early adopter which you are in which i
am like
you're early right and if that's true
and all of our friends are early
adopters and we're all early on
something we should be buying that stock
right yeah so
yeah so i i follow the same uh
kind of strategy in that i have two
buckets i have so
one we should both say neither of us are
registered investment advisors and this
is not investment advice this is just
like what you
do personally two things
my sister what will i tell her i'll tell
her
don't buy any individual stocks buy
wealth front
go into wealthfront get a bunch of index
funds play it safe do your thing
set yourself up for retirement you're
done so one bucket
of my portfolio is like that it's just
like
ultra safe like slow growth
nothing fancy lots of index funds blah
blah then
there's the okay let's take this
and this is different for everyone in
terms of what what their allocation
would be what but some percentage of
your overall
um net worth and say i'm going to take
that and invest in something that i hope
will have a blended 3x over the next
five years right or
4x whatever whatever you're kind of
aiming for and for me it's
it's the same bucket so i was thinking
okay
heading into covid what are the things
that are going to do
better which would be a peloton because
you know gyms are closed it's a
fantastic product
the churn is effectively zero because
when someone else
buys a bike that is being sold used a
new subscriber is then activated
which is crazy it's one of the very few
products that has like zero churn
um and you have to imagine they're
working on and they've hinted at this
publicly
they're working on other types of
equipment right so it's not just one
trick pony they already had a treadmill
they pulled it back they said they're
revamping it like that's
so it's you know and it's a like right
now even today
it's a 19 billion dollar company like
if you think of this more as a
technology subscription play and the
future of fitness
i think there's a much larger business
to be built here and you know we were
talking about this when it was under 10
billion in market cap so
that's interesting amazon obviously to
your point about
e-commerce penetration being relatively
low in the united states
this there is no bigger goliath there is
no bigger
giant than this you know beast of a
company and it's like they're just going
to continue
to crush everything and so for me that's
not a 3x because it's already a 1.8
trillion dollar company or whatever it
is now like
but it's you know there's some there's
there's still some growth to be had
there
and and it's like i i'm not betting
against e-commerce ever
and especially in a covered world people
are going to be shopping and doing more
shopping online so i
i like that um square
i love how they diversified their their
product offering square cash is a
fantastic app
so it's not about brick and mortar it's
now about you know
they're doing stock trading they're
doing bitcoin purchases which they've
made a ton of money off
this last quarter um it's about building
out
that suite of personal finance tools for
the unbanked
um directly in that cash app which is i
just think
you know it i'm so to my point earlier
about the three to five x you have to
look
at lower market cap companies you can't
be looking at an
apple or an amazon for those types of
returns over time
so you know square's a 67 billion dollar
company there's
i believe there's there's more room to
for them to grow there um
like you on shopify for everything
you've said uh
tesla same thing i think it's expensive
right now
but i mean they're they're continuing to
build up these massive gigafactories
there's a reason why every other week
they're like announcing a new
gigafactory like the demand is there
and they have a fantastic product um
yeah i i just love
it's hard to bet against them here's one
that's interesting that i haven't told
you about
so i don't know if you know this but
intel is kind of screwed right now
they've had a really hard time with
their chip manufacturing and getting
this this
new process down the smaller diet chips
amd has been crushing them but here's
what's interesting
so apple also moved away from intel
chips and now is now doing their own
chips right
so apple and amd but apple is not using
amd apples using their own silicon and
doing everything
so who makes all these chips it's a
company called tsm
out of out of taiwan that makes all
these next generation they're like the
better version of intel
so tsm i think is going to be i mean
they're already a 375 billion dollar
company so they're not tiny
but but tsm is massive and now also
consider this
we're going into the fall two things are
happening playstation the new
playstation the new xbox
are coming out both of them amd
architecture
both of them being manufactured by tsm
in terms of the chips themselves so
i i'm excited about tsm um and then you
know
i buy some some gold to hedge all of
that uh and then that's pretty much
about it i got oh you know
spotify dude i think spotify is gonna be
seen
as the netflix uh of audio and
eventually we'll get into video as well
and i i think it's gonna be um there's a
reason they haven't launched joe rogan
on in the app yet and i think it's
because
they're revamping my my gut tells me
they're revamping the player
and they're going to announce video at
the same time and it's going to be like
spotify is gonna be like the
next netflix well i think that was so i
i agree with you and i
i one of the disgust publicly discussed
but
under discussed aspects of that deal was
the inclusion of video
that that his show would be coming off
of youtube
and going into spotify right this is the
thing that's the thing that people are
like oh yeah and they're doing the video
thing but
okay but look at the audio and look at
the price of the deal and i'm like no no
right that video is super [ __ ]
important right pay attention to that
that's a big big big deal it's huge
yeah yeah those guys are smart they're
really smart
do they have the michelle obama podcast
now that's exclusive to spotify and like
i was it's funny i was talking to talk
about like speaking of early adopter
stuff i was talking to
my wife daria and she's like you know
she just had this conversation last
night she's like
ah google podcast is crashing for me she
goes you know what i'm just going to use
spotify because everything's there and
they got
some exclusive content now and i was
like ding ding ding like
that's just you know it's going to be
the default
yeah they're smart and they're being
very very aggressive in ways
uh that some of their competition
really can't i mean they they
technically could but they're just not
designed
to be aggressive in the way that that
spotify is being aggressive
and i'll be super curious to watch the
space obviously because
you know i play so much of the podcast
world but
uh do you think you'll ever join them i
don't know
i don't know i mean the it would have to
be an incredibly good offer i
i do i've thought about this quite a bit
i mean as it relates to different
options right because
there there have to be some responses or
reactions from the big players right
like
apple amazon google are all going to
put a lot of capital and energy into
this space because there's
there's money to be had and if anyone's
playing with music
they recognize that the margins and
advertising dollars are much more
interesting
yeah the economics are much more
attractive for podcasts and spoken word
right i mean look at look at audible
right what a monster
uh so dominant another reason that i'm
bullish um
actually one of the one of the reasons i
i was really bullish on amazon
is i said and this actually came from a
friend of mine mike who pointed out
and he said what is going to happen with
live sports
how are they going to broadcast sports
to millions of people who is equipped to
handle this
right now and he's like amazon with
twitch is equipped to handle this in
some fashion right like there are
there's infrastructure within amazon
that can be adapted
for all sorts of gaps
in the market um so well the beautiful
thing is that amazon gets paid no matter
what because like
who guess what happens when google taps
out their data centers what they light
up next they're lighting up
amazon yeah exactly everybody's letting
up aws
when this stuff goes goes big exactly so
uh let me ask you a question about you
you mentioned
a couple things real quick so yes
confirmed
that we are not registered investment
advisors and i think it's really
important for me to
provide a little more context around my
comments where i said i put in
you know enough chips where it would
would be meaningful with say amazon
and shopify man you said spotify i
always confuse the [ __ ] out of those too
i put when i put money
into both of those companies i had
roughly
14 times more in cash reserves
so this is really important to keep in
mind in other words
at the time right if i put 2 percent of
my liquid net worth
into those stocks i had something like
30 percent in cash or cash like reserves
right so i'm playing it from my
perspectives kind of safe
in that respect and i do not recommend
people stock pick
in general i just think it's a terrible
idea uh
and and the other thing too is if
if you're gonna if you're gonna play in
this world like
there's no such thing as timing the
market and you just never know what's
going to happen like
always dollar cost average your way into
any position so that that means like if
you have
500 to invest rather than say tomorrow
i'm gonna go buy some spotify for 500
bucks and just call it a day
like maybe divide that into five 100
investments over the course of five
months or three months you know
you're not buying at the bottom you're
not buying at the high but you're
getting that blended dollar cost average
and a lot of people do that to
as a little mini way to to hedge and and
you know because who knows what's going
to happen given how insane this market
is
the second piece that i think is
important to mention is and i think tim
you're in this boat too but
i wouldn't be buying anything that i
wouldn't want to hold for the next five
plus years
so it doesn't really mean that's super
important i should have said that i was
planning
on not touching these for three to five
years
yeah so i mean if if something drops by
40
will i be crushed by looking at the
price of course but is
i think long term i'm going to be in a a
just a
you know fine position and that's the
way you kind of you
you alluded this too it has to be
something that you're comfortable losing
at the same time right so it shouldn't
be the life savings right yeah and we
should also say
it's like we're talking about companies
that we actually really [ __ ]
know right some level right i mean
not this doesn't mean that it's a
different type of knowing
than reading every analyst report and
it's just like a deep product knowledge
and the fact that like we both like i i
know dozens and hundreds of companies
that
use shopify right as their ecommerce
solution
i use amazon every day for one thing or
another
and i think that's important to keep in
mind
and question about uh i think my dog
really has to pay so i'm gonna take her
out in a minute she's
being very good we can we can we can
wrap things up we can wrap things up
i'll
this this would be a good way to
expedite the the answer to my question
which is
you said you're buying gold how do you
think about gold versus crypto because
you've been
very involved or knowledgeable of
and tracking crypto for
for quite a long time and are you buying
etf are you buying
uh you know bars in some vault in a
foreign country what are you doing
yeah why gold versus crypto how do you
think of them about them differently
well on the gold side i like to look at
the etfs that
that do warehouse their own gold and
actually have
you know full transparency reports about
actually owning the bars and
you know so i i actually buy the eye
shares gold trust which is iau
and i like that a couple
that won their the the biggest one out
there is gld
but their expense ratios are higher um
iu uh i believe there was a couple
things i looked into and
that it's also like like like providence
like where were they keeping their gold
as well and iu had was keeping in
switzerland
and i think one i think the uk as well
and it just i want to make sure where
they're storing it is also
safe and secure and not because it's not
a crazy war zone or something else that
could you know potentially go really
bad on that front bank of sierra leone
yeah it's like you know
so you know i just i i went with that
one there's a i'm sure
they're all the big ones are all
probably pretty decent but
in terms of crypto you know i have
a bunch of cryptocurrency that is not
yet
tradable that um i've invested in over
the last few years and so that hasn't
hit the market yet so i already see my
crypto bucket as being pretty full
i don't think um holding bitcoin or
ethereum
is a bad idea i just wouldn't make it
any substantial
portion of my overall portfolio like i
wouldn't it wouldn't be 10
or something crazy you know why do you
have less confidence
in crypto than gold if i'm that's a
leading question but i'm just making an
assumption here
and that does not to imply that i am a
super bowl with crypto but it seems like
in some respects you are more confident
in
gold as a disaster hedge versus crypto
why
why would that be the case if it's true
well i just it is true
and i believe that you have to look
uh at what are the
safe asset choices that institutional
investors have direct access to
and um there is no easy way
you know etf uh to buy cryptocurrency
it's just not there yet and and i just
um
it's not to say that people won't turn
to crypto and the prices won't you know
5x by the time this
video is released like who knows but i
just
i know that gold is so time tested that
i i just
i feel it's it's it's a it's a proper
it's a it's a proper hedge and i'm okay
with with with having some portion of my
portfolio being gold
now do you view that as a hedge against
hyper inflation the hedge against
general equity collapse what are you
hedging with gold
i would say a little bit of both but
mostly general
general equity collapse like just
something i'm hedging
in that i believe if all
like let's just say we have a vaccine
that doesn't work and this turns into a
three or four year process
instead of a one year and change process
jobs don't come back
that's going to be a pretty brutal place
to play right like
the markets i think at that point might
start to sour
it's very confusing why they haven't
today but like you know
in that case i i would like a little
more
something a little more something that's
a little bit more concrete like having
gold as part of a portfolio but that's
that's just me everybody's
different i have some friends that won't
touch the stuff so and then i have some
friends that actually have bars and
they're
like actual physical gold bars which you
know some of those people as well
i do yeah you probably no i don't i
don't actually but i'm just like i'm
like if it gets that bad
right where it's like mad max and
marauders are you gonna drive your
[ __ ]
dune buggy with machine guns down to the
7-11 and like take a razor blade and
shave off a sliver of gold to get your
tampons
like no you're not right like tim's on
the corner with like a little
little hatchet like like etching off
some gold and like trading it for some
lentils
if it gets that bad like you're gonna
have to use your gold as a weapon
because it's not gonna have any
functional value but i mean who knows i
mean
it's uh god it just feeds every
like not paranoid but sort of
apocalyptic
scenario planning compulsion that i have
which so i try to i try to not get
wrapped up in it
so it's so seductive it's so seductive
yeah
cool well thanks for thanks thanks for
answering that yeah i
um i think people should be prepared for
a long haul
right like it's it's i think it's very
dangerous to try to do any short-term
trading
and i actually heard an anecdote i'm not
going to mention
any names but one of the
one of the best known hedge fund
investors in the world who has an
incredible incredible track record i
mean the guys
his compounded annual returns which over
decades is it
are just ludicrous and he came in
this is a couple weeks ago and basically
like said to his team he's like guys
it's too [ __ ] hard just like take a
vacation we're not gonna do it we're not
gonna try to
deal with this right now so if
that is happening in like one of the top
shops in the world
i don't think it's a good idea for
99.999 of people to do any short-term
trading you're gonna get eaten alive
uh either by other traders who do this
24 7 or high frequency folks
or you're just going to get murdered by
the market right
as the saying goes the market can remain
irrational longer than you can remain
solvent
yeah um it's it's crazy when you read
these reddits uh
subreddits about you know these robin
hood traders that are using that app to
leverage their positions
and like these kids are going in there
and just getting these crazy leveraged
positions on certain things i mean
they're driving up bankrupt
companies like hertz and all these to
like new record highs and you're just
like this is not
we shouldn't be playing don't don't play
with this stuff well that one kid that
poor kid
i don't know did you hear about what
happened i don't know there's a lot of
pockets
okay which one are you talking about
this one got um
so you know robinhood the app it's it's
a fantastic trading app it's a great
piece of software but it allows people
to opt in to
options trading and leverage trading
like with like three clicks it's like
super
terrifying oh i know so so these kids go
in
and this one kid put in i don't i don't
know what the dollar amount was but he
he got on the wrong side of being
leveraged and it saw he saw
i mean he didn't know these things were
going to expire and he saw like a
negative like i don't make a number but
it's something like a hundred thousand
dollars negative account
and he killed himself oh my god all over
robin hood and this and just a
misunderstanding of what was going to
happen in the end
and just got so wrapped up doing it and
it's just
i it's it's yeah it is
honestly for me you know another reason
why i'm just
hitting pause on all this stuff is that
you know for me these days like the
function of investing
and that can be applied to time and
energy but certainly
capital is to increase your quality of
life
right so if if if one agrees
that that is let's just take that as the
primary objective
if you're making investments that cause
you to lose sleep and
chew your fingernails and have cortisol
pour out your eyeballs it's a bad
investment it doesn't matter if 2x is
10x is 100xs
if for a protracted period of time it's
going to have that psychological
psycho-emotional effect on it's not a
good investment
and you know i've learned that the hard
way too right i've chased returns
certainly in the startup world and all
this stuff and i was like this [ __ ]
sucks like this is not fun and even if
you're good at it doesn't mean you
should do it
like watch after this podcast comes out
like venison futures are gonna like
shoot up and like
venison is the future maui get after it
cool man well it's awesome to see you
brother and yeah
miss hanging out and uh it's a bummer to
not be able to spend time in person so
hopefully we'll be able to do that
before too long
yeah i agree dude it's been been too
long it was i'm actually really glad
that you got to visit us just before
this whole coveted thing happened you
know it wasn't that many months before
so it was good to see you then but it's
uh
it's been it's it's tough it's tough
stuck in the house all the it's hard
with significant others too you know
it's like you really realize what your
relationship's made of
but uh you get you get to see all the
stuff yeah exactly
and all your stuff i've got no shortage
of my stuff you know it's a daily
project
and anything else you want to say before
we wrap up no
people can find you anything like that
yeah i mean i'm not on
social really these days i do tweet
every once in a while
at kevin rose but um yeah if you i would
say one thing i
would like to mention is if people want
to check out um that zen interview i did
on my podcast
with henry i thought it was quite good
it was like you know and i'm sure you
tim you get like this to you
you probably obviously don't say it
publicly but you record episodes you're
like
episode was just okay you know it's like
yeah you know sometimes you're like
every once in a while you get one of
those yeah yeah so this one i was like
wow i actually
i think i did a pretty decent job with
this one so i was pretty proud of it so
i think people will enjoy this one with
with henry schickman
and you can find that at
podcast.kevinrose.com
sweet and for me uh
really loved doing the hugh jackman
interview that must have been huge for
you it was amazing yeah it was just a
dream come true i mean he's been on the
wish list forever and he just was so
game
so so if you want to check that out i
think it's just to listen to
you i gotta listen to it because darya
was like did you hear that tim
interviewed hugh jackman i'm like oh i i
was lusting out of my mouth because i
was like
he must have been [ __ ] himself like
that's like yours
yeah i was super nervous uh it was great
it was great so
you know did you ask him about his
training and stuff i did yeah oh i knew
you would have yeah
i was like if you could only choose one
exercise what would it be and why and
what would the protocol be
he he gave he really gave the details
and got out
oh that's exciting that's awesome so
that one i'd recommend people check out
if you just search
my name and hugh jackman or go to the
your podcast app of choice and then also
i'd say
one thing that i am still doing that i'm
still really enjoying is five bullet
friday which is the newsletter that goes
out to between one and two million
people every friday it's free it's just
five bullets of the five coolest things
that i've come across that week or that
i'm
thinking about using experimenting with
pondering and you can find that at tim
dot blog
forward slash friday and sweet
that's it for me man but uh give a give
a hug to the phantom for me miss you
guys
yeah miss you guys too and uh yeah let
your dog go pee
yeah all right molly molly thanks us for
getting off
all right all right brother
all right
you